hey what's up guys my name is a chana
and welcome back to my say plus plus
series today we're gonna be talking all
about operators in C++ and operator
overloading in C++ so first of all
what's an operator well an operator is
basically some kind of symbol that we
use usually instead of a function to
perform something so I'm not just
talking about mathematical operators
that we have such as plus minus divide
you know multiply all that kind of stuff
but we've also got other operators that
we use very commonly and we've actually
been using quite a few already these
include things like the dereference
operator the arrow operator plus equals
there's the ampersand operator that we
use for memory addresses we've also been
using the bit shift left operator which
is to left angular brackets for printing
out stuff into our set out into our
console and then we've got other
operators which you probably don't think
of as operators at all such as new and
delete they're actually they're also
operators and then we have entirely
different operators which are weird such
as the comma operator yes the comma can
also be an operator as well as the
parentheses yeah that's right - like
brackets - parentheses that's also an
operator I'm not gonna list off all of
the operators we have available in C++ I
will make videos specific videos about
some of them because they think they
need some talk me about but if you want
to see the full list of C++ operators
that exist then I've linked a reference
in the in the description below so
operator or the learning what does that
mean well the time overloading in this
sense just means kind of giving a new
meaning to or adding parameters to or
creating essentially in the case of
operator overloading you're allowed to
define or change the behavior of an
operator in your program this is a very
very useful feature that isn't supported
in languages such as Java it is
partially supported in languages such as
C sharp usually the good parts of it are
supported but C if I suppose kind of
gives us full control and that's kind of
it's kind of a good thing but it can
also be a bad thing and that's just the
case with C++ it gives you so much
control but it can lead to so many bad
programs and people heading on the
language I might actually
a video just talking about all this
because I know that a lot of people are
interested in that but at the end of the
day operators are just functions they're
just functions instead of giving your
function and name such as ad you can
give it an operator such as plus and a
lot of cases that really helps to clean
up your code in streamliner
it'll just it just looks better and it's
easier to read however in other cases if
you're using the ampersand operator to
push a variable into a data set what are
you doing looking at you boost
serialization really at the end of the
day your use of operator overloading
should be rather minimal and only in
cases where it makes perfect sense if
people need to go to the definition of
your operator or the definition of your
class or struct or whatever to see what
it actually does then then you've
probably failed for example when
defining a maths class and you need to
add two mathematical objects together
than overloading the plus operator makes
perfect sense because you can literally
write code like a plus B and it will
work in fact let's take a look at some
examples I'm going to write a bet to two
struts so basically what this is going
to be is it better to it I've decided to
make it a struct because the fields are
going to be public it's going to have
two floats and X no why that's all the
vector two is it's a two component
vector I'm going to define a constructor
quickly for this which just takes in an
X and a Y and now it's like I mean we
can actually start to create these
things so let's just say that I want to
store a position and maybe a speed as
well okay great so I've got two vectors
and now I would like to add them
together and stall the results say over
here so I come to the problem of what do
I write well in a language without
operator overloading or if you're in C++
but you don't want to use operator
overloading and you would probably write
something like position dot add a speed
so if I go up here we'll quickly define
the add function this is going to return
a brand new vector2 we'll call the
function add it's going to take in an
existing vector two will pass this by
constants to avoid copying well mark the
function as constants it's not going to
modify this class it's just going to
create a new vector two with the result
and we'll just return it back to two x
plus other dot X
and why plus other dog why okay seems
pretty simple we've got this working
here it looks relatively okay but what
if we wanted to modify our speed by some
kind of modifier we might have had a
powerup that changes our speed to be
slightly faster maybe 10% faster or
something like that
suddenly we want to be able to do
something like speed times tower up so
with this current set that means that we
have to write code like speed multiplied
power up we have to add the multiply
function so I'm just going to copy and
paste this add function change it to
same multiplier and just change the
operators here to be the multiplication
operator okay cool now this is where it
starts to look a little bit hard to read
and unfortunately in language such as
Java this really is your only choice but
in C++ we have operator overloading
which means that we can take advantage
of those operators and actually define
our own to deal with the vector to
struct so potentially instead of writing
something like this we can convert this
to just use the mathematical operators
so we'll do something like position plus
speed times power often with operator
precedence playing a role here this
should get evaluated before this so
let's pop up here and define true
operators the multiplication operator
which is just an asterisk and this
addition operator which is the plus sign
so the way that we define these is like
any other function we write the return
result which of course is going to be
the exact same the return type is going
to be the same as it is for these
functions so for our case we're writing
out over here let's move this our PS
that we can kind of group them instead
of the function name we write the word
operator followed by the operator which
is plus we then open up our parentheses
and type in the parameter that we want
so really you can see it's exactly the
same and then we write cost at the end
of this because like any other function
that doesn't modify a class like this
add function we still we still want it
to be Const and then what we can do is
just return the same result or in this
case it would be much simpler to just
return a dhaba and that's it we've
created the plus operator if we come
back here and we're just comment out the
rest of this code you can see that this
code is fine I don't forget we can
compile this and it will compile and
everything is great now since things are
like any other function
I could have basically done the reverse
of this instead of this operator calling
the add function I could make the add
function call the plus operator and a
lot of people actually don't know about
this because the syntax looks a bit
weird and you don't see this very often
but what you could do is just change
this to be basically that and then over
here in add we're going to either return
and this plus although which is kind of
the easy case I guess we're converting
this we really need to make a video on
this because the this keyword is is
quite special and we need to talk about
that there'll be a double card up there
if that's already done whether you're
referencing it because this is
originally a point or a constant pointer
in this case whether you're referencing
it to just turn this into a normal
vector to and then we're just adding it
with our but that's pretty common people
write code like that
a lot but what we can do is just address
this operator plus like a function by
just writing return operator plus and
then other again it looks a bit weird
but totally going to compile and it
totally works
me personally do to just go style I like
to return the code like this instead
okay cool so to complete this we'll just
add our multiply operator I'll copy this
operator plus pass it over here and
change this to be operator x or operator
multiplier and we'll change this to say
multiply now if we uncomment this then
you can see that we have this code here
which in my opinion looks much much much
better than this and it makes a lot more
sense okay great so as I said I'm not
going to go through every single
operator because that would take all day
and it's probably not that useful I will
make future videos on operators as we
use them or as I see fit however I will
show you one more operator and that's
the left shift kind of operator that we
use with SC BC out so surprised look now
that we've got this vector two we want
to actually print it to the console
esidisi house as you probably would have
noticed has this kind of shift left
operator which takes in various types at
the left side we've got the CR class and
of the right side we've got some kind of
data types so we'll type and result two
which is that vector and then we'll
we were just able to do this now we
can't do this because there is no
overload for this operator which takes
in an output stream which is what CRTs
and then an actual vector too but we can
add that so outside of the vector to a
class because there's nothing to do with
vector we're just adding this to see out
what we're going to do is write STD or a
stream which stands for output streams
of reference so this is the original
kind of definition of this operator that
I'm overloading here we're going to
write operator left shift inside here
we're going to take in the class because
you can see this is a definition outside
of class so we still need a reference to
the existing stream which in this case
is going to be C out and then I'm going
to pass my cost vector by reference here
over here I'm going to say stream and
then shifts basically whatever I want to
print so in this case alpha dot X the
stream already knows how to print a
flirt so we don't need to overload the
flirt or anything like that
and there may be a comma and then a bird
or Y and make sure that you've cost
right
oh stream here and I'll string like like
me okay so this is what it looks like
and then finally we need to return a
reference to the stream which is just
this stream so we can just get returned
stream and that's it you consider this
code now compiles and if I run this code
we'll get four point five five comma
five point six five printing which of
course is the right answer
so there we go that's a look at a few of
the operators that we can overload in
C++ and our just operates work in
general room but they're just functions
and remember just because you can
overload an operator and make your code
look weird don't because it's going to
make it harder for people to read is
probably going to annoy you yourself and
it's just it's just bad just bad code
style don't do it this let's shift
operator that we overloaded just kind of
like the two string function that you
commonly override in languages such as
Java or C sharp and so that's one of the
great things about C++ you can kind of
have operators instead of functions
another great example which c-sharp does
support but Java doesn't is the equals
equals operator in Java you have to
write an equals override for every class
if you want to be able to compare it and
then later on you have to write equals
everywhere so
compare result one result - I'd have to
write it for result 1 equals result 2 or
something like that or maybe if it
doesn't equal I would write that and
that just looks a little messy so
instead of that we also have the option
of writing B equals equals operator
that's the final one that I'll show you
guys for today because I I wanted to
show it flow right pool because that's a
returned resolved cost can return true
or false
operator equals equals constitu
reference other const because it's just
a comparison we're not going to be
modifying this class and we'll just
return x equals equals x and y equals
equals other del y so we're basically
checking to see if this floats are
exactly the same crawling down here we
can change this code to say something
like result equals equals resolved to i
can see that works have a big fan and
finally if we wanted a not equals
operator we with a copy this code change
this to not equals and then just call
basically the opposite of equals so
we'll call this equals equals other but
we'll put this in parenthesis with an
exclamation mark at the front to reverse
the result of that alternatively with
the kind of syntax that I showed you
earlier you could write something like
return operator equals equals other and
then kind of reverse that result and
return that that looks weird
don't do it that way if you are doing it
this way which you probably should
pretend this well maybe alternatively
just have an equals function and call
pad and return the reverse of that or
something like that again you have these
oprah's that some people prefer not to
use them when creating a library I like
to add birth so I would still have a
like like I did over here I would still
have this add function but I would also
have an operator so you've basically got
your peasant your best for giving anyone
using our API choices as to what they
want to use hope you guys enjoy this
video if you did you can hit that like
button and you can support this series
by heading out
I am home for such the chair I hear that
people they are getting videos early
like every day which is pretty cool so
if you wanted if you want to jump on
this train early earlier than anyone
else and get to see the videos early as
soon as possible
as soon as I'm done editing them they go
up on patreon do you guys want to get on
that train then link in the description
below you're also ensuring that I have
more time to make these videos which
results in more videos so fun for the
whole family I will see you guys next
time
good bye
[Music]